Do you need to take the Dutch integration exam
but not sure if it's A2 or B1?
Then listen up.
It basically depends on two factors
your visa or residency type
and the date that the IND
formally decided that your integration period started.
If you are a refugee or if you have a partner visa,
you need to focus on the date that IND gave you.
If your date is before January 1st, 2022
then your level is A 2.
If it's on January 1st, 2022 or after
then it's most likely be one.
If you're here on a temporary visa
and you wanna apply for permanent residency
or citizenship
then it's still A two.
The government wants to raise the level to B one,
as you know,
but it's not sure when
and if it's gonna be in 2024.
It still has to be discussed.
So if you pass the A2 exam within a few weeks or months,
the level might remain A2 for you.
And if you wanna pass the
A to integration exam as soon as possible
then take a look at my newest offer
The Inverting Crash Course.
Check out the caption
and if you want all the info
then comment the word info and I will send you a DM.